[Musique]
bon je vais essayer de faire marcher la
vision nuit sur la caméra tu pourrais
peut-être monter un étage
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai pris une
longue toge d'accord tu peux être happé
la grande valise y aura plus de place
pour toutes nos affaires j'entends rien
de ce que tu dis c'est quand même
vachement mieux de filmer dans le noir
merci pour moi je suis pas ce que je
voulais dire attention tu es prête pour
trois jours de folie entraîne toi
d'abord sur moi parce que ça risque de
bouger un peu plus la main par habitant
à images est pas terrible mais à deux
pas et pourtant ton visage ressort comme
une grosse tache blanche inerte c'est
quoi ça derrière toi c'est pas la peine
d'aller se perdre dans une église pour
trouver des fantômes en a partout comme
ici s'il le faut
tu vas bien vite et me chercher j'ai
entendu parler de l'église de clope et
bien sûr elle est assez vieilles et on
la connaît plus sous le nom de l'église
sainte marie elle se situe dont le
perdre forte qu'ailleurs
elle a été construite en haut d'une
colline il y a cinq cents ans elle
surprend bell village c'était l'église
paroissiale de toute la région à
l'époque victorienne avec l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle architecture de nouveaux
bâtiments mais aussi à cause d'une
population qui s'était occupé on a dû
construire une nouvelle église toujours
appelée sainte marie situé plus au
centre de la ville en expansion mais
malheureusement l'ancien fut totalement
laissée répondant avec le temps elle est
devenue une sorte de chapelle mortuaire
elle ne jouait plus son rôle d'église
tel qu'on l'entend
puis les gens commençaient à la
dépouille est entièrement quand il ya
plus deux plombes
c'est là que les trucs bizarres ont
commencé à arriver par exemple le bruit
courait que certaines personnes
l'utilisait pour faire de la magie noire
et vénéré diab elle était connue pour
être un lieu de rassemblement et de
culte étrange notamment à halloween
vous savez où des personnes se
retrouvaient pour faire de la magie et
des rites mystique
quand on passait près de l'église en
voiture on voyait parfois du feu à
l'intérieur
clope et l'été célèbre dans les années
60 et 70 non seulement on savait qu'il
s'y passe et des messes noires mais les
gens parlaient aussi d'apparition de
vision en tout genre jusque dans les
années 1960 tout le monde
fish est cet endroit mais dès lors il
est devenu le siège de phénomènes
paranormaux si vous voulez pour beaucoup
de gens cette église a commencé à
représenter un haut lieu du surnaturel
ok salut tout le monde
donc nous sommes vendredi matin et le
soleil brille pour le moment pour
l'instant on est en train d'essayer de
tout casser dans la voiture pour
rejoindre les autres mais en fait là on
est un peu en retard donc je crois qu'il
est temps que j'avais trouvé ma femme
pardon faudrait qu'on s'active
on a pris pas mal de retard d'accord eh
ben je suis quasiment prête je prends
juste sans plus j'ai encore tous à
mettre dans la voiture et chérie oui
j'ai envie de prendre la croix du christ
avec nos lacs est la grande celle qui
est accroché au mur en guise de
protection qu'est ce que t'en dit un
conseil ou deux avant qu'un live ma
chérie bonne chance et tu prends ton
chapelet
j'en ai déjà dans mon sac petites manies
il pense qu'on va avoir des choses ouais
ça va être vraiment cool ramener un
souvenir
vous allez voir tes vrais fantômes un gp
arrêt fantôme m c'est pour ça que nous y
allons pour en trouver mais ce sera de
vrais fantômes
est ce que tu en penses toi oui c'est
vrai tu pense qu'ils vont se montrer
enfin tu aurais peur si tu voyais
infanto pas peur du tout parce que quand
je vais dormir
il ya des fantômes gentil près de mon
bureau
avant tu lèves encore mal maintenant je
croyais que c'était fini depuis un
moment
des sorcières quoi les sorcières
mais sans jeudi matin les sorcières
elles sont jeunes ils sont gentils mais
c'est des fantômes
un petit conseil pour moi - faut-il les
fantômes qui ont des gros yeux sont ceux
qui sont les plus gentils d'accord alors
ils sont gentils quand ils ont des gros
yeux c'est ça mais sorcière leçon je
garderai l'oeil ouvert
et s'ils n'ont pas de gros yeux ils
peuvent quand même être gentil c'est pas
trop je suis prête à fermer la porte de
derrière
oui chef j'ai été embarqué sur ce sur ce
projet parce que parce que je suis ami
avec avec kevin et mike les producteurs
du film depuis quelques années il était
au courant que j'avais une expérience
avec un fantôme dans le passé et c'était
intéressant pour quelqu'un comme moi
parce que je n'ai jamais vraiment été
dans ce genre de trip de toute ma vie et
fantômes la vie après la mort tout ça je
n'y croyais pas vraiment en fait je n'ai
pas de religion
je n'ai jamais jamais été baptisé non
plus donc ce domaine n'était pas du tout
familier mais quelque chose ayant trait
au paranormal m'est arrivé je ne peux
pas réfuter cela kevin était au courant
alors il m'a demandé de faire partie de
ce projet il pensait qu'avec mon
expérience ma présence sur le terrain
serait un atout et que je pourrai
l'aider dans ses recherches lui donner
mes impressions une fois sur place à
l'église de club il j'ai entendu parler
de clope il pour la première fois il ya
une vingtaine d'années les gens
parlaient d'une église en ruine sur une
colline dans laquelle elles ont pratiqué
la sorcellerie et qui apparemment était
tournée pile dans la direction de satan
il y avait aussi la légende du fantôme
de sophie harvin on racontait tout un
tas de choses
un vieil ami à moi de l'université de
bedford m'a contacté et m'a envoyé la
vidéo de sa propre étude sur l'église de
club il
il est parti là bas avec une équipe de
chercheurs et ils ont passé la nuit
ils ont posté des caméras un peu partout
dedans dehors sur les murs la nuit s'est
bien déroulé il ne s'est rien passé
d'étrange à leurs yeux
mais lors du visionnage de leur
enregistrement il y avait des choses
inexpliquées
ces espèces d'apparition sur la bande
lors ont fichu la chair de poule et
sachant que je réalisais des films ils
se sont dit que ça pouvait m'intéresser
alors ils m'ont appelé et c'est là que
l'idée de ce projet a germé
bonjour et bon réveil sa marque salut ça
va super bien ça fait plaisir
il fait trop chaud c'est la peur à
chaque fois qu'on tombe pour un film ça
déconne ça fait trop longtemps
ouais des années salut crise vous en
êtes où ouais je descends avec mike et
marc parce qu'ils s'en vont
garez-vous dans le parking de l'hôtel je
vous attends au bar vers l'entrée le
plan patriotique avec l'union jack en
font pas mal je m'appelle mark stephens
j'ai 29 ans et je suis réalisateur de
films à wolverine tonnes tu crois au
paranormal
je suis pas sur l'idée d'une vie après
la mort ne me choque pas en fait je n'ai
jamais vu ou eu d'expérience avec des
fantômes mais je préfère garder un
esprit ouvert
à propos du paranormal et des phénomènes
dans ce genre suis complètement ouvert à
au fait qu'il y ait quelque chose un
autre là en plus il ya tellement de
preuves que ça donne vraiment réussi on
a fait quelques caméras ce week-end
kevin m'a parlé du projet il ya quelque
temps son objectif est d'enquêter sur
des phénomènes paranormaux en fait tu es
mon rôle sera celui de la présentatrice
j'interviewe vrai aussi quelques
personnes
kevin a pensé à nous parce que nous
avons déjà eu affaire à des fonds comme
dans le passé
et voici notre homme vivait là le voilà
regardez-moi ça non mais quel sérieux je
vous jure je n'ai constituer qu'une
petite équipe et vu le thème du film il
nous fallait des personnes en qui mike
et moi avions confiance nous avions déjà
travaillé avec craig crise et sachant
qu'ils avaient partagé une expérience
avec le paranormal
nous voulions qu'il soit la robe était
plus sceptiques c'est un cartésien
en revanche marc mike et moi même sommes
plus ouverts donc il ya un beau mélange
d'opinion l'endroit est absolument
renversant c'est vrai dans honnêtement
on a vu des photos tout ça mais
franchement rien que le fait d'être ici
c'est tellement rare de trouver des
endroits pareils très chargé
historiquement et oui le nulle part
c'est magique on nous là on peut dire
que le soleil est au rendez vous
aujourd'hui à raison je suis super vous
j'espère que les esprits sont aussi au
rendez-vous ce week-end ma foi parce que
jamais avec certaines parties à la plage
dans leur église de vacances oui on a
toujours entendu des histoires au sujet
de l'église il ya une rumeur qui dit que
le pasteur a vu un fantôme là-haut dans
l'église il l'a lancé lui-même cette
rumeur et c'est à cause de ça que tout
le monde a commencé à y aller pour faire
de la magie noire
c'est à partir de ce moment là que la
réputation de cet endroit est né d'abord
il est hanté puis la magie noire
tous ces trucs là le révérend barker je
me souviens de lui comme quelqu'un de
vraiment très gentils et de bonne
composition
mais il aimait bien la bouteille le
pasteur je me souviens il se balade avec
un sac rempli doses qu'ils montraient
tout le monde ici c'était drôle il
n'était pas fou je vous assure et j'en
suis sûr c'était des autres quoi bah
c'était des zoos humains je crois bien
qu'ils avaient été utilisées pour de la
magie noire dans l'église là bas vous
connaissez les personnes qui pratiquent
cette magie noire
non non ni même droit vient de nous
rejoindre les peurs il sillonnait le
soir portée avant le lever du jour vous
savez vous n'y êtes jamais à lille ce
soir si j'allais soir tous est fou
pourrait que j'ai perdu la boule pour
les me promener la nuit monsieur les
morts foulée laisser se reposer
les habitants de clope il était plutôt
intéressant la plupart y habite depuis
très longtemps voire depuis toujours
donc on avait l'impression qu'ils
avaient énormément de choses à raconter
sur ce qui se passe dans leur village
et on aurait vraiment dit qu'il n'avait
pas envie de les raconter justement
peut-être parce qu'ils en ont assez des
touristes indiscrets des questions qui
reviennent toujours
je ne sais pas où il se protège si
j'habitais la clope il
j'aimerais que sa réputation
disparaissent du fait que l'église soit
hanté on s'aperçoit vite qu'il n'est pas
possible d'enquêter
il y a beaucoup trop de gens qui y
viennent ce qui rend les recherches
compliquées
ils ne viennent que pour se faire peur
parfois
et ça je suis sûr que les gens du poids
n'apprécie pas du tout c'est un endroit
extrêmement calme n'exagère pas il n'y a
aucune maison autour
si il y à une ferme aux alentours mais
elle se situe tout en bas de la colline
donc assez éloigné on se trouve sur un
site vraiment reculer dont la première
habitation est un kilomètre ceux ci
traîne une réputation une très mauvaise
réputation parce que c'est là que des
groupes de gens font leurs messes noires
ces gens s'amusent à invoquer le diable
ou des forces obscures en général on est
arrivés sur le site un peu après midi
pour poser toutes les caméras et faire
un peu le tour du site
j'ai été agréablement surpris bien que
les murs étaient tous recouverts de tags
un peu spéciaux il régnait une
atmosphère très paisible nous sommes
entrés dans l'enceinte de l'église avec
des symboles et des inscriptions
sataniques sur les murs on les trouvait
partout puis par terre entre demeure on
a aperçu quelque chose qui dépasse et
c'est quoi ça je crois que c'est une
pâte
c'est dégoûtant
maintenant j'y crois pas à ces quoi tu
vois ce que je vois c'était de grosses
dents on ne savait pas quoi en penser
on était dégoûté c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on trouve des dents par terre
alors est-ce que c'était des dons
humaine ou animale c'était difficile à
dire attention sur la salue sinon on est
regardé sous cette pierre qu'est ce que
c'est une corne il y avait une corde à
côté du mur dans merde vous savez
entendre les histoires de club il vu par
les habitants la magie noire tout ça
puis voir des éléments qui font penser à
de vrais sacrifices
c'était assez troublant on a tout de
suite été plongés dans l'univers de ce
site et on ne s'attendait pas forcément
à voir tout ça paraît normal ou pas les
choses qui se passe là bas relève
vraiment du blizzard elle semble que
quelqu'un a fait un feu ici n'ont en
effet rien à je crois savoir
je pense qu'on est à l'endroit précis où
le rituel a été découvert en 63 il était
au beau milieu de la nef à wiggins
dollars en mars 1963 une des tombes qui
se trouvait aux alentours de l'église
fut exhumé c'était la tante de gender
stone elle était l'épousé d'un
apothicaire on avait retrouvé ses
ossements disposer au beau milieu de la
nef de l'église en forme de cercle
son crâne empalé sur une espèce de lens
et des plumes de coq les placer en forme
de cercle
je me souviens c'était en mars 1963
calvin smith un ami et moi même avons
fait luton club il à vélo on est monté
sur la colline pour voir l'église sainte
marie où je me tiens en ce moment
la première fois que j'ai vu l'église je
me suis dit en moi même quelle beauté
à propos des ruines vous voyez il n'y
avait aucun bruit
on entendait les grillons c'était très
agréable
puis nous avons découvert le crâne et
les os et là tout a changé
la journée avait débuté sur une belle
note et c'était fini en abomination
attendent de djénine rolston oui saison
ont été sortis de la pierre tombale est
allé par terre comme pour pratiquer un
rythme où une messe noire quand kelvin
et moi avons regardé sous l'arche le
crâne et elle a planté sur une grande
pointe en faire il y avait les os du
corps si on les avait disposé tout en
rond autour de la boîte il y avait des
symboles de magie noire et décroît
dessinés sur les murs et on avait aussi
allumé un feu je ne serais pas surpris
que des individus aient amené des chiens
pour surveiller l'entrée de l'église
afin de ne pas être dérangé j'ai détaché
le crâne de son perchoir et calvin a
pris les hôtes y était par terre et on a
gardé tout ça dans les mains je ne sais
pas pourquoi il faut dire qu'on était
tellement chantier vu un couple est
arrivé nous ont vus en train de porter
des eaux
ils nous ont crié dessus et puis sont
allés prévenir le pasteur quand kelvin
et moi on est redescendu par le petit
chemin le pasteur et à policiers arrivés
à grandes enjambées et là ils nous ont
ramenés en haut pour qu'on explique ce
qu'il s'était passé il ne nous croyait
pas il nous accusaient d'avoir profané
la tombe à 1000 a fallu cinq policiers
le pasteur pour remettre le couvercle
sur la tombe ils ont compris alors que
de gauche n'aurait pas pu faire ça le
révérend barker était plus ou moins
connus pour ne pas avoir eu beaucoup de
chance par exemple il a perdu sa fille
dans un accident à shefford
un automobiliste lui a roulé dessus je
ne crois pas que son état psychologique
était très bon après 5 ou après la
sphère des messes noires à clopes il
je pense que le pasteur barker buvait
pour oublier tout ce ce qui s'était
passé
cette affaire l'a beaucoup éprouvé
psychologiquement et finalement il a
voulu se débarrasser de cette église
c'était sa solution pour stopper les
cérémonies funèbres et la magie noire
on est venu ici je crois entre 2006 et
on est arrivés vers minuit il y avait
personne à saint-herblain on s'est
baladé ce côté ci mais on s'est arrêté
là parce qu'on a vu comme une épaisse
forme blanche au dessus des tombes
la forme était là bas et on s'est
regardés en même temps et puis on s'est
retourné la forme s'était rapproché à
quoi ressemblait cette forme à peu près
1 mètre 50 je dirais imaginez-vous
maintenant ici dans le noir et vous
voyez une forme d'un mètre cinquante
avec une tête des épaules et le bas
s'enfonce dans les hautes herbes
on aurait dit que enfin qu'elle était
juste porter là et tout à coup elle a
fait quoi 8 ouais c'est ça 8 à 10 pas en
avant en l'espace de quelques secondes
en deux secondes vrai elle avait l'air
de venir vers nous à ce moment là en
fait eux ils sont restés mais moi
j'étais pas très courageux alors j'ai
pris mes jambes à mon cou et j'ai
découpé j'avais pas envie de venir
aujourd'hui dr bureau
je suis là maintenant c'est pas un
endroit très nette si vous voulez mon
avis donc vous étiez ici
ouais ouais c'était ici on est chez nous
allons regarder vers les tombes on
voyait bien la forme blanche parce qu'il
faisait nuit noire
d'accord le blanc se détacher de la
forme était pas là quand on a tourné au
coin de l'église en fait c'est quand on
a passé l'arche exactement à regarder
droit devant constatant il ya un truc
bizarre et entre le moment où on s'est
regardés moment on s'est retourné
la forme était vachement plus proche le
problème c'est que quand on en parle aux
gens ils ne croient pas mais vous vous
avez l'expérience avec les esprits alors
vous nous prenez pour se servir
c'est pour ça que je suis venu
d'ailleurs vous allez essayer de voir ce
genre de truc ce soir là et bien enfin
je ne sais pas du tout à quoi s'attendre
on a entendu différentes choses et on
voudrait enquête et un peu si je vois
complètement ce que vous voulez dire
ouais c'est vrai ou pas ou je ne sais
pas mais j'espère que mon avis vous
devriez poser les caméras par l'arrivée
juste là toute cette partie à la dérange
pas sur part parce qu'ils voient comment
sérieusement le problème ça se comprend
il ya une histoire très intéressante que
sony par marc nous a raconté il a eu du
mal à revenir à clapiers la presse qui
lui était arrivé il craignait de revenir
sur le lieu où
il avait vu cette forme blanche en
général quand on est en situation
d'hallucination collective
il suffit d'une personne pour faire
naître le délire et le reste du groupe
se met à croire qu'il voit la même chose
mais quand on a deux personnes qui
simultanément son témoin d'une
apparition très troublante et qu'en plus
l'apparition s'approche d'eux comme ça
en l'espace de quelques secondes
tellement rapidement qu'il ressente le
besoin de s'échapper en courant
alors ça ne peut pas être une
hallucination collective parce que
l'action est trop rapide
alors greg tu veux annoncer le programme
de ce soir là on est juste en train de
vadrouiller sur le site histoire de
tâter le terrain voir qui sont ces gens
qui viennent visiter les lieux la nuit
et observer ce qui se passe
en france pas trop par là
certes
[Musique]
entendu ça dit moi je les entends du oui
est-ce qu'il ya ce côté là crie ça
descend jusqu'au petit bois de l'église
jours
à toi kevin
y'a quelqu'un là-bas
t'es sûr je n'arrive pas du tout ouais y
avait quelqu'un c'est sûr
alliant sens mal et à se répartir
ouais d'accord
chérie tu veux dire un mot sur notre
charmant pied-à-terre on est dans un
hôtel un bed and breakfast du nom de how
is beautiful
et voyez par vous même c'est beautiful
world
un travail qui est là je me demande
c'est le grand mike salut salut à la
chasse aux moustiques gillot c'est la
guerre contre les faux choix et je crois
que j'en ai eu un aussi bon alors
bonnery en soit demain drac mon pote
bonne nuit
ban et on se voit au petit déj ça marche
ok attend on reprend gentiment journée 2
jamais sans mon chapelet d'îles moins
une chose est ce que tu as plutôt peur
d'être dans le noir est ce que c'est le
fait de retrouver nez à nez avec un peu
des deux je pense en fait je n'aime pas
être dehors la nuit sans lumière et
c'est quelque chose devait toucher ma
jambe
serait-ce que feuilles ou vent mais du
fait qu'on soit ici dans ce lieu
effrayant je pense qu'aussi peut-être
que l'imagination peut nous jouer de
saké tour66 et comme tu le sais j'ai une
imagination très fertile
l'avant ce jeu rapetissement voilà la
tombe de sofia à la mémoire de notre
sofia épouse bien aimée de bennett
stimson steam stimson qui est décédé le
28 juin 1915 à l'âge de 70 ans
c'est un bon début naturellement on va
se promener un peu plus et essayer de
voir s'il n'y a pas d'autres sophie ou
sofia c'est déjà une super retrouvailles
bien sûr que ce soit elle mais c'est
franchement intrigant qu'elle soit là
sous cet arbre pas d'autres tombent
autour mystère qu'est ce que tu caches
sofia seul sur sa colline l'histoire
raconte qu'un fantôme et a bel et bien
été vu un couple venu visiter l'église
en 1972 a pris une photo du côté de
l'église où il y avait une fenêtre sur
la photo est apparue comme une forme de
couleur blanche dans l'encadrement de la
fenêtre la forme flottait à peu près à 1
m au dessus du sol
les gens du coin ils ont alors rappelé
sophie le fantôme de sophie
les activités que nous allons
entreprendre ce soir sur ce site vont
être très différente de ce que nous
avons fait ici dans le passé parce que
cette fois nous allons procéder à une
véritable enquête
le deuxième soir william et la société
du patton nous ont rejoints pour l'anc
est la dernière fois qu'ils étaient là
où il avait vu quelque chose mais des
jeunes les avait dérangé cette fois on a
une équipe de sécurité avec nous donc ce
devrait être plus facile on pourra
essayer d'expérimenter et voir où ça
nous mène c'est très paisible comme
endroit il ya quelque chose elle stinson
décédé le 5 9 ans cahuzac et surtout une
autre sofia on dirait absolument bonne
idée on devrait les faux nez on a un mot
je ne sais pas encore lequel
là où c'est là aux épouses de la sofia
et plus de l'os de arthur et samuel
steam somme pourrait bien mettre frère
parce que les dates de naissance et de
mort sur leurs tombes datent de la même
époque mais leur femme s'appelle toutes
les 2 sofiane a donc y en a deux de
sofia
kevin tu penses que tu pourrais éteindre
et rallumer ta caméra s'il te plaît et
pourquoi parce que là j'entends comme un
cri je ne sais pas d'où ça vient et
c'est très aiguë la part d'un côté ouais
ça va de plus en plus fort je l'éteins
si un mec avec une tronçonneuse terre
non ça vient pas de là rallume là
ah c'est mieux déjà pas mal c'est pas
mal rapproche toi un peu robe andy beal
estèphe se tenait plutôt par là après
l'église sur ce côté dit et moi on était
en train de parler quand j'ai vu une
ombre qui passait derrière on était en
train de prendre la mesure des champs
électromagnétiques au botnet
il avait détecté une autre fréquence de
ces champs à cet endroit et c'est là que
sarah a vu quelque chose derrière nous
sans savoir ce qu'elle avait vu j'avais
aussi ressorti comme une présence là où
andy est dépassé legault se mettre la
confirmer moi je me tenais par ici et
vous à côté de ces herbes
en fait entre les herbes et les tons oui
à quelques mètres pas très loin du tout
cela nous ramène à une question est ce
que ce site est hantée ou pas on est
allé voir les endroits précis où les
gens disent avoir vu ou ressenti qu'il
se passait des choses et on en est venu
à la conclusion que tout s'est passé à
l'extérieur de l'église
plus exactement autour de ces pierres
tombales que personne n'avait l'air de
connaître avant qu'on ne les trouve
on en est au 2e jour et on se dirige
vers club une voiture pour voir la
police dans deux petites minutes
une conductrice hors pair est parmi nous
et heureusement vu l'état de la route
c'est clair il ya beaucoup de crevasses
sur cette route non ça y est on arrive à
l'église messieurs dames
sous un beau ciel étoilé pas un seul
nuage à l'horizon
ouais on dira assiette de pln d'ailleurs
la nuit est claire c'est génial que
jerry est plus libéré j'ai demandé à la
police qui lui montre où se poster à la
boîte aux lettres le super mon rôle je
m'appelle gerry mcgovern je suis agent
de sécurité privée engagée pour
surveiller le site de l'église sainte
marie j'étais bodyguard pour des
célébrités je travaille sur des
tournages de films en extérieur ça fait
25 ans que je suis dans ce milieu et
j'avoue que je me suis ennuyée marie
avec dana nous avons deux filles et un
garçon mon cousin m'a appelé un soir et
m'a proposé ce job il a dit que michael
bartlett avait besoin d'un agent de
sécurité
voilà comment je me suis retrouvé à club
il l'année dernière on a appelé une
équipe de sécurité parce qu'il ya trop
de jeunes qui viennent la nuit a clôt
pile on aurait simplement pas pu
travailler dans le calme
jerry et les membres de son équipe se
sont postés à toutes les entrées de
l'église de manière à ce que personne ne
puisse entrer ou sortir vous installer
des caméras d'appoint là ce sont des
installations que j'ai imaginé on à
l'appareil photo d'un enregistreur dvd
et on a aussi un enregistreur audio pour
les eaux et p les outils nécessaires à
votre enquête sur l'eau à l'arrêt au
moment de caisse comprendre et bien
c'est très simple on en prend autant
qu'on en veut voilà et j'ai vu des
personnes qui n'ont besoin de rien si ce
n'est d'elle-même parce qu'elles pensent
que le meilleur outil pour détecter un
fantôme
c'est nous mêmes on peut le voir
l'entendre le sentir j'ai tendance à
emporter tous les objets électroniques
qui me passe sous la main des appareils
à vision nocturne et appareils photo
numériques des micros des enregistreurs
des gosses m qui servent à mesurer le
champ électromagnétique lorsqu'à fantôme
est dans les parages les champs
magnétiques environnants change et c'est
ce changement qui indique s'il ya un
fantôme une entité aux alentours
d'accord s'il ya des ondes
électromagnétiques les lumières
s'allument une autre chose qu'on devrait
mentionner c'est que on doit s'ouvrir à
l'endroit où on est parce que on est
vraiment dans un lieu
l'un des éléments peuvent nous
influencer vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
la pleine lune et toulon les ruines etc
si jamais elle devait pleuvoir les
orages
alors ça c'est c'est le faisceau de
lumière hockey qui va éclairer là ou là
où on pense que le fantôme de sophie va
apparaître donc mon conseil se serait on
ne s'approche pas en fait sarah et moi
on se prenait une pause et on s'est
rapproché du côté des tombes
là on a aperçu le type de la sécurité on
s'est arrêté net parce qu'on entendait
comme une personne qui se déplaçait
bruyamment dans les airs quelqu'un ou
quelque chose qui se déplaçait en
faisant bouger les broussailles
on s'est avancé on n'a rien vu du coup
on a fait le tour est même allé jusque
sur la route et on n'a rien vu pas
d'animal personnes à rien et puis
l'agent de sécurité nous a dit qu'il
avait entendu ce bruit pendant cinq
bonnes minutes avant qu'on ne vienne en
ai parlé trois à l'avant c'était quelque
chose de très lourd ça pouvait pas être
un animal trop trop bruyant on aurait
t'il pas de quelqu'un marchant sur sur
les feuilles sèches vous savez le bruit
qu'elles font quand on marche dessus
à ce prix là c'est la tombe dont vous
parlez je savais pas qu'il y avait une
tombe
mais les bruits viennent d'ici de ces
puits sont et septembre
oui c'est ici qu'on dirait que quelqu'un
se promènent d'accord on va faire un
silence total de duda connu tu es voir
ce qui se passe
je pense que le mieux c'est d'envoyer un
caméraman ici parce que j'ai franchement
l'impression que quand on fait une
activité là bas c'est ici qu'il se passe
des choses s'arrêtent là
il ya eu un bruit là bas on reste alerte
et on écoute ça peut recommencer
merci du riz vraiment bhl deux d'entre
vous restent de ce côté et deux autres
un peu plus haut la raison à ça c'est
qu'à chaque fois que quelqu'un a vu
quelque chose cette chose se déplaçait l
aller dans cette direction
donc si par exemple une entité arrive de
par là et que vous ressentez quelque
chose quoi que ce soit il faut le dire
ne restez pas sans parler d'accord donc
quoi que vous ressentiez si vous vous
mettez à frissonner par exemple mal au
crâne je ne sais quoi il faut que vous
le disiez c'est important parce que si
vous sentez un truc de ce côté et les
autres certains trucs là bas c'est
qu'une présence est passé est ce qu'il
ya quelqu'un qui a oui quelque chose
l'an passé allez on se donne les mains
je prends le sens du froid stef thema
sont gelés désolé les tiennes sont super
chaud d'un jeu sous yat il une présence
ici qui voudraient communiquer avec nous
y at il des esprits présent parmi nous
qui voudraient entrer en contact
si oui nous vous demandons de nous faire
un signe par terre il ya une lumière
verte d'autres lumières s'allument quand
il ya des champs magnétiques pouvez vous
activer ses lumières
nous avons deux enregistreurs à nos
pieds si vous laisser une trace sur ces
enregistreurs nous pourrons vous
entendre des gens ont vu une silhouette
se promener là où nous sommes
etes vous pouvez vous nous dire qui vous
êtes
venez vous installer dans notre cercle
il ya une agitation et ça bouge bien
c'est là bas oui ça vient vraiment
direction t ce côté ça venait de
derrière
j'ai eu un frisson ah oui respire
lentement ou le long du dos je vais
aller voir ce qui se passe c'est bill ça
je sais pas quelque chose a bougé juste
là je vais leur demander
oui c'est inquiétant si ce n'est pas lui
mais c'est sûr vous avez vu bill il est
passé par là non oui les arroseurs du
oui oui ça leur fait écouter
il ya quelqu'un
ça fout la chair de poule
mais pour cent qui est là c'est certain
il ya quelqu'un à mémoire oui ça me
donne froid dans le dos n'aie pas peur
c'est rien
la voilà
encore et toujours [ __ ]
effia
j'y crois pas quoi mais je sais pas je
marchais vers je me rapprochais de la
tombe de l'autre sauf hier oui pour
faire un gros plan de la pierre écoute
je sais pas si mes yeux me joue des
tours ou quoi mais tu as fait quelque
chose
j'ai vu un truc genre on peut passer
devant mais ça devait être la lumière à
ok je comprends pas mais j'ai avancé
tranquillement
j'étais à mi chemin je sais pas ça
venait peut-être des branches au dessus
de moi il y avait un craquement en fait
même moment où je m'approchais de la
tombe
comme pour me dire que j'étais pas le
bienvenu nous allons maintenant utiliser
la boîte à fantômes une boîte à fantômes
n'est rien d'autre qu'une radio modifié
et elle a été modifiée le telle sorte
que quand vous appuyez sur le bouton qui
cherchent les stations s'il fonctionne
bien le scan de la radio se déplace
entre les fréquences se bloque sur une
fréquence et stop
ici la radio va constamment scanner le
principe est simple vous poser une
question et vous obtenez une réponse de
temps à autre selon la question le scan
va prendre des bouts de phrases sur
certaines stations et vous entendez
parfois une réponse à la question que
vous avez posé et c'est surprenant le
nombre de fois où ça arrive d'une
certaine manière ça fonctionne un peu
comme la planche ouija ce genre de
choses le but premier étant de lancer un
appel d'attendre une réponse d'accord
[Musique]
ouais
y at il une personne ici à qui vous
voudriez transmettre un message
si vous voulez faire ça dit plus comment
la personne s'appelle
simpson stimson oui comment vous
appelez-vous votre prénom
sofia ça suffit t'es sûr j'ai entendu
sofia bref je crois société sophia
changer de place allez on fait ce qu'il
dit on change de place étaient sous la
forme sombre que sarah a vu du côté
nord-est de l'église à l'extérieur oui
est ce qu'il y a quelqu'un avec qui
aimerais communiquer avec l'un de nous
ici si oui pouvez vous dire son nom
j'ai entendu jerry c'est ça
avez-vous dit thierry oui c'est une
jerry vient de nous rejoindre
avez vous un message pour jerry seah wee
communiqué nous le message
c'est lui j'avais un message pour moi
enchantée est-ce que vous avez bien dit
craig voulez-vous me dire quelque chose
est-ce que vous avez un message précis
un communiqué
regardez cosmed s'emballe oui toutes les
mrc
quelque chose de blanc étaient juste là
sur le haut de la pente ici c'était une
forme assez grande je dois dire vous à 6
qu'est ce que tu as vu c'était un truc
blanc tu vois où les robes là bas il y
avait une forme blanche à droite ou à
gauche ici à là où elle était je pense
qu'il ya pratiquement la longueur d'un
terrain de foot elle allait tout droit
il ya une ombre qui se déplacent vers là
maintenant hélas elle revient de ce côté
là ça me fait froid dans le dos l'a fait
un aller retour sous mes yeux c'est
incroyable grande forme longue et fine
elle faisait sans dire de bêtises à peu
près 1 m 70 de haut et se déplaçant sur
4 m elle se pencher en avant comme ça de
toute évidence elle avancer très vite
alors j'ai cru qu'il s'agissait d'un
chien
j'entendais quelque chose qui respirait
fort dans les fourrés là bas
comme du mouvement droit devant dans les
fourrés ça vienne par là depuis tout à
l'heure
tout se passe ici tous concentre sur
cette zone il ya beaucoup de
bruissements qui vient de par là on
aille voir ça de plus près peu importe
où on va c'est de laeken c'est de là que
viennent tous les bruits qu'on entend
seulement cette zone
ban
c'est complètement fou
ouais
là c'est quoi ce bordel [ __ ]
de dieu c'est quoi ce truc berd au
ça ressemble à un oiseau cd tête
d'oiseau
parlant de gerry l'agent de sécurité
nous a demandé à mark et moi de venir
voir
il entendait une respiration ou un
bruissement ou quelque chose
il m'a fait faire 5 pas sur la gauche il
a montré les buissons et je vous ment
pas pile sous sa main derrière les
buissons il y avait la pierre tombale de
sofia et là je me suis demandé tu
connaissais l'existence certes on a en
personne ne lui a dit et il ne
connaissait pas le nom de la personne
ouais je sais pas il a dit qu'il avait
entendu comme la respiration forme d'un
chien non oui comme celle d'un chien il
a d'ailleurs dit que littéralement il
s'attendait à voir un chien way sortir
du du petit buisson
alors vous en pensez quoi à quoi on
s'attend demain soir je pense que ce
serait réellement intéressant si on
était juste entre nous demain oui plus
il ya de personnes présentes
moins on a de chances qu'il y ait
quelque chose qui se passe je pense - on
est pour observer et apprécier un
phénomène quand on est trop nombreux on
est plus à même ne pas être d'accord sur
les choses qui arrivent d'habitude c'est
quand on n'est pas nombreux
c'est là que les légendes et les rumeurs
naissent en général on n'entend jamais
parler de l'histoire où un groupe d'une
douzaine de personnes étaient ensemble
et ont vu ou ressenti la même chose
exactement c'est pas possible on peut
pas être 12 au même endroit et avoir
tous le même ressenti c'est en règle
générale des petits groupes
genre une deux personnes tu vois ce que
je veux dire je sais pas vous avez
remarqué comment ils ont vraiment tout
essayé pour que ça marche tous les
gadgets était là ça marche c'est pas
parce qu'on arrive avec des boîtes
magiques et des planches ouija et plein
de trucs dans le genre qu'on est en
mesure de communiquer avec eux qui que
ce soit je ne dis pas que ce ne sont pas
des personnes décédées mais qui qu'elle
soit comment on peut savoir si ces
appareils fonctionnent vraiment qui a
dit que c'était le moyen de les faire
communiquer avec nous comme on sait que
c'est ce genre de choses que les esprits
veulent utiliser alors j'ai du mal à
croire que qu'on peut comme une fin
c'est mon avis qu'on puisse communiquer
avec quoi que ce soit de cette manière
mais on peut être témoin de choses
visuellement
beaucoup de gens l'ont été je crois je
crois en sa tu veux le tableau qu'on va
interviewer aujourd'hui c'est ça ouais
ouais j'étais présent lors des activités
satanique de 1970 il a dit on voit au
fait on en est aujourd'hui numéro trois
derniers jeux l'église en ce matin du
troisième jour ouais derniers jours
hourra c'est bon de savoir qu'on va
rentrer et me tarde de bien dormir ce
soir tient pas appelons le le jour final
jour final le jour finale kévin et mike
légion sont jusque là aussi il y un
troisième peut-être et moi c'est à lui
présente milk peeters pollitt vous
rencontré craig commence à germer
pieters est arrivé là haut avant nous
histoire de se préparer avant
l'interview
il était présent lors des messes noires
des années 70 35 ans ça fait un bail
alors je me suis dit que je me baladerai
un peu avant de voir j'ai pas emprunter
le chemin dans les herbes je suis arrivé
directement à l'entrée j'ai pris des
photos et je suis entré et là j'ai vu je
pense que c'était un harvey c'est un
petit lézard quand même dit serpent si
vous voulez en forme de s c'est bizarre
c'est qu'encore une fois on rencontre as
tu ne fais pas la collection enfin c'est
par ici
comment il est arrivé là
le fameux est ce un serpent peut-être en
fait c'est un harvey c'est à la forme
d'un serpent
c'est peut-être de hasard mais il est
quand même posé en forme de s est assez
symétrique
ouais c'est sûrement fin ville au milieu
de l'ouverture ok je comprends ce que tu
dis mais essayant de garder la tête
froide
il ya un vide crécerelle là oh ouais
bien sûr c'est vrai qu'on ne sait pas
comment il est arrivé là mais bon ça
reste quand même intéressant je pense
est intriguant encore une fois aux
marocains ailleurs l'accord exprès de
serpent au bas de la tour est en forme
de s ma première réaction a été de
penser aux fantômes de sophie et aux
deux pierres tombales à son nom
coïncidence ou pas c'était quand même
vraiment très étrange
est ce qu'un oiseau a laissé tomber le
serpent plier sur lui-même comme un s
agité avec mon frère et quelques années
en 1975 pour halloween et à c'était
l'occasion on était jeunes curieux on
s'était un peu intéressée à l'eau culte
on avait entendu parler de sainte-marie
a clôt piles et on avait envie de la
visiter au moment où on est entré sur le
parvis re la vue des lumières dans
l'église
je me rappelle pas avoir entendu quoi
que ce soit on la continue de
s'approcher de l'église on observait
depuis les côtés c'est là qu'on a vu un
groupe de personnes dans l'église
on les a vus très distinctement c'est à
ce moment là qu'on a entendue comme une
salle maudit
je dirais pas que c'était une rythmique
de chant grégorien mais il chantait
quelque chose ça on en était certain les
kiss et éclairés par des torches et des
sortes de grosses bougies ce genre de
truc mais on a continué vers le fond du
parvis et ans au fil entre les pierres à
ce moment là on a bien su clairement
deux adultes mais c'étaient des femmes
cette fois et elle était nue elle était
entourée d'autres personnes qui
portaient comme une tache de couleur
pourpre
enfin c'est ce que j'ai vu leurs appuis
sa parenté fortement celui des moines on
était toujours allongé dans les herbes
quand tout à coup on a entendu un gros
boum
moi j'avais l'impression qu'il
s'agissait d'une arme à feu on s'est dit
que quelqu'un nous avait repéré qu'ils
tirent en l'air pour nous faire peur
alors on a pris nos jours à notre goût
un pion s'est enfui de ce côté et puis
on a ré atterri sur le chemin une fois
qu'on a atteint le bout du chemin là où
commence la route
un camion et des voitures de police nous
attendait et c'est drôle parce qu'il
nous accuser de causer des problèmes
ils nous disaient de rentrer chez nous
qu'on avait rien à faire là et nous on
avait beau le répéter il faut que vous
montiez là haut il y a des gens qui font
des messes noires alesi nous ont envoyé
balader continuer de nous dire de ficher
le camp
il agissait comme s'il ne croyait pas
mais après en avoir discuté avec mon
frère plus tard peut-être qu'ils étaient
au courant et qu'ils couvraient ces
personnes ou tête que la police
elle-même avaient peur de parler
je suis heureux de le jour d'après parce
qu'il y avait encore beaucoup de
questions qui me trottaient dans la tête
j'ai garé ma voiture un autre endroit et
chez entrer dans l'église
j'ai pu voir que beaucoup de croix avait
été abîmée envers ces églises étaient
pas dans un meilleur état
il y avait des bougies brûlent et
partout c'était le cas au lot le pire
c'est qu'ils avaient des eaux par terre
jupe un médecin légiste mais j'ai
clairement reconnu une vertèbre
sur le mur du côté droit de l'église
tout au bout du mur vingt deux mois
était gré moi je pense qu'on les avait
écrit eric du sang ils disaient mais vd
à l'époque j'avais aucune idée de ce que
ça voulait dire on m'a dit des années
plus tard que ça voulait dire pas de
futur en latin et avait bien eu quelque
chose j'en ai déçu qu'ils étaient en
relation avec l'occultisme et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire pour moi c'est une
évidence
j'avoue pas se voir s'il existe vraiment
des masses satanique ni comment elles se
déroulent mais d'après ce que j'ai vu
s'en était une c'est évident kevin
faisait l'interview il reste l'équipe
n'était pas loin je m'étais mis en
retrait et je surplombait la scène et là
j'ai remarqué quelque chose d'étrange
milk avait trois écorchures sur son bras
3 écorchures juste ici est ce que dans
l'occultisme on retrouve ce phénomène
des trois langues et cultures des échos
reçus à anvers ce sera en fait les
démons qui attaque parce que d'après les
croyances en faisant ça ils se moquent
de la trinité on a filmé ça de près
parce que c'est tellement insolite et le
fait que lui-même n'ai aucune idée de
comment elles ont pu arriver là c'est
déconcertant les différents des
glissements les formes que peuvent
prendre les démons dépendent vraiment du
contexte dans lequel il se manifeste il
faut faire attention à ne pas confondre
les démons et les fantômes
ils ne sont pas pareils les ventes home
sont les esprits en fait d'être humains
décédés et tu n'arrives pas à passer de
l'autre côté
en revanche les démons n'ont jamais été
humain les des mondes sont des hommes
spirituel et on les appelle aussi les
anges déchus
mais ils n'ont jamais vécu en tant
qu'humain avant d'être des mondes et
crève d'envié de pouvoir passer dans
notre monde
nous nous trouvons ce matin au milieu
d'un bois quelque part aux alentours de
l'église de clap il est passé par là
pour atteindre l'église parce que vous
l'entendez peut-être mais il ya comme un
bruit de tambours très fort et ça vient
de l'église donc on s'avance dans cette
direction mais c'est vraiment fort on
dirait un train non non assuré philippe
et c'est vraiment détestable c'est plus
en plus fort c'est une sorte de rituel
certainement
on m'a discret ne faut pas qu'il me vois
tu ne sens pas de la fumée il ya un feu
on va passer par derrière c'est plus
pour filmer de là je ne pense pas qu'ils
nous verrons
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si vous pouvez encore
entendre les dames dame est ils sont
posés juste derrière nous et je ne veux
pas c'est pas une bonne idée de les
déranger
on va continuer parce sentiers je crois
que l'église est sur la gauche
quelque part on va s'avancer essayé de
s'approcher et sans bruit si on peut je
vois des pierres tombales je commence un
peu angoissé les pierres devant tu les
vois ouais ouais éclaire un peu un voilà
tu vois ça voilà à lapin à la part tu
vois ouais c'est dans la boîte petit
c'était un à part fortement les pierres
tombales sont ici donc ce doit être
c'est à gauche qu'on tourne non
ouah on vient enfin d'arriver à l'église
alléluia
[Musique]
ça s'est passé quand on était en espagne
chris et moi on était en vacances et on
avait loué une vieille ville à l'été
avec nos deux filles
c'était à peu près il ya deux ans 2008
donc la petite avait 4 ans c'est sur la
grande la v10 et la petite cabine
elle aime bien venir nous faire coucou
dans notre champ elle passe à côté du
lit pour venir me voir et souvent elles
réclament un bisou un verre d'eau où
elle veut juste dormir avec nous une
nuit on dormait bien tranquillement il
était deux heures du matin et tout à
coup je vois kathleen entrer dans la
chambre à petits pas il s'est avancé à
côté du lit en tentant la main elle me
dévisageait je ne savais pas ce qu'elle
voulait mais elle venait vers moi c'est
à ce moment là que comme tous les soirs
je lui tends la main
j'attrape la ciel la serre un peu je
vois si à la fin ou si elle peut parler
mais je vais pour tendre la main
elle se tenait aussi près de moi que tu
l'aies toi même en ce moment je baisse
ma main qui passe à travers ma fille
elle a disparu s'était pas kelly elle
s'est simplement évaporée sous mes yeux
inouï je suis resté là et tout ce que je
n'arrêtais pas de penser dans ma tête
c'est quoi ce bordel
elle est passée où
et là je me suis levé je suis sorti dans
le couloir jusque dans leur chambre
c'était une chambre à part et juste pour
vérifier que enfin c'est stupide parce
qu'elle a disparu sous mes yeux mais je
voulais je voulais être sûr que cassis
et kathleen était bien là j'ouvre la
porte et je les vois elles dorment sur
leurs lits comme je les ai jamais fait
dormir
donc je ne sais pas qui c'était du tout
mais ce n'était pas qu'elles viennent et
quand on pense aux fantômes on s'imagine
des êtres volatile des êtres transparent
mais ce n'est pas vrai la plupart des
fantômes convois sont solides
si vous croisiez un fantôme dans la rue
vous le prendriez pour une personne et
non un fantôme
en fait vous pourriez même le toucher ou
penseriez qu'il est là et c'est quand il
disparaîtrait que vous comprendriez dans
l'avion du retour
je lui ai dit j'ai un truc à te raconter
alors je veux commencer à lui dire et je
m'attendais à ce qu'elle soit au moins
un peu effrayé par ce qu'a longtemps et
là elle se tourne et me dit un truc
comme c'est quoi
je sais pas ce que c'est mais tu lui a
foutu le bonbon avec les histoires d'à
qu on en dirait bien oui je disais que
je pensais qu'elle aurait un peu peur de
mon histoire de fantômes étant donné
qu'elle est restée dans cette villa
pendant quoi quatre nuits mais elle
s'est tournée il m'a dit papa c'est cool
je ne voulais pas le dire parce que sur
le moment je croyais que mon imagination
s'emballe et j'étais dans le cellier
quand ça m'est arrivé je rangeais une
pièce de vêtement et puis j'ai passé la
tête par la porte vers le couloir et
j'ai vu où j'ai eu l'impression de voir
comme ça une ombre
ça vient de là le mur est en train de
s'écrouler ou quoi c'était keyyo on
lance des cailloux sur le mur comment tu
sais j'ai entendu aussi tu la porte en
une c'est sûr derrière moi ça fait un
bruit sec
c'est intéressant ça vient de là quelque
part par là n'est pas tout seul
bon allez ça recommence
je les ai vus c'était pas moi c'est des
gamins que jettent des cailloux non un
truc à voler jusqu'en jerry s'il a vu
personne dehors on me jetait des pierres
par les fenêtres elle atterrit c'est
tout près de nous elle frappait d'abord
les murs ça faisait pas mal de bruit et
c'est arrivé sans qu'on s'y attende
bref on a continué de parler et puis
rebelote les lancers se faisait de plus
en plus précis et ça m'a rendu nerveux
pas tant à cause du fait de ne pas
savoir qui faisait ça mais surtout parce
que je ne voulais pas en recevoir une
sur la tête un des garçons est sorti
voir jeter un oeil
mais encore une fois il n'y avait pas un
chat la soirée commençait sur une note
assez bizarre et mystérieuse mais encore
une fois se retrouver avec aucune
explication
j'entendais toutes sortes de bruits
après les bruits oui il ya eu des choses
que j'ai vu des choses plutôt étrange
je suis curieux de nature et ça fait
aussi partie de mon métier donc je vais
respecter les lieux ces genres de choses
qui me fait pas peur
j'ai posé la lampe torche si c'est pas
de la lampe torche avec moi dans le
wydad de m'envoyer de vie sont là à côté
de la pierre blanche j'ai vu comme une
sorte de figure noire et elle allait
d'ici à là
c'est exactement ce que les autres
témoins on voudrait dit que j'ai froid
sur le moment j'ai même frissonner ghosn
c'est comme si mon corps entier
s'étaient mis à fourmiller ce truc est
parti de ce puits sont à gauche pour
aller sur la droite et je les ai perdus
j'ai relevé ma lampe torche et même pas
une seconde après il n'était plus là
j'ai été informé par par l'équipe du
film que deux jeunes avaient vu la même
chose au même endroit ils ont vu une
ombre venir vers eux avec une très haute
rapidité de mouvement
je me trouvais là exactement aussi quand
je les ai vus j'ai entendu des pas
derrière moi et on aurait dit que
quelqu'un était en train de courir dans
les buissons en direction des pierres
tombales et c'est là qu'on a vu une
grosse ombre bouger au loin j'ai cru que
c'était un rêve
je me sens vraiment vraiment très
bouleversée j'ai froid j'ai des frissons
je tremble j'ai juste très envie pleuré
j'ai senti mon corps se refroidir des
pieds jusqu'au cou et j'avais la chair
de poule de partout et mon corps s'est
arrêté de bouger j'ai commencé à pleurer
je ne me sentais vraiment pas bien comme
un trop plein d'émotions rien que d'en
parler je sens monter l'émotion
on s'est même posé la question tous les
deux on s'est demandé est ce qu'on a vu
cette chose là pour donner la réponse
est oui nous avons tous les deux des
frissons au même moment parce que jamais
vu ça avant
c'est bizarre pas vraiment je comprends
pas
ce niveau là c'est de la science fiction
dieu s'il vous plaît protégez-nous
veuillez veiller sur nous si on ouvre
une porte fait qu'aucune entité ne reste
de notre côté quand on la referme
parti dans les faits tout à l'heure les
autres sont sur la planche wizzards et
nous on va voir les tons pour voir ce
qui c'est une caméra avec eux et une
avec nous comme ça on pourra voir s'il
se passe des choses en même temps des
deux côtés dirait qu'il fait plus noir
d'un c'est le cas
esprit êtes vous la faites nous signe
est ce qu'il y a les esprits présent
parmi nous manifestez vous s'il vous
plaît pouvez vous communiquez avec nous
en bougeant le pointeur
s'il ya un esprit ici présents qui
voudraient entrer en contact avec nous
faites vous connaître la regardez
regardez plus active
les cinq lumières étaient allumées
j'espère qu'on ne l'a pas fait fuir
je voudrais montrer que le gosse m on
est branché à rien du tout il fonctionne
tout seul salut notre côté on se met
entre 75 et 100 avec mike terminée voilà
jerry lee drôlement précédent qu'est ce
qui se passe ça va durer là là il ya
quelque chose là on était là où vous
êtes
on l'a vu dans cette zone là une ombre
se déplacer très rapidement ce côté-ci à
la c'est drôle on a quelque chose ainsi
dans l d'anna était là il ya deux
secondes l'ombre était à droite et pouf
à gauche dana aperçu et moi aussi mais
j'en étais pas sûr elle m'a assuré
l'avoir vu c'est là qu'elle s'est
déplacée
je vous ai prévenus nous on a capté
quelque chose aux gosses m quand chris
poser une question il répondait
justement chaque fois il répondait aux
que j'essayais d'en poser moi aussi ah
oui craig a aussi essayé rien du tout
comment va ta nana oui elle va bien ma
score elle s'est remise et le fait de
voir ça ça va un peu secoué le mettant
surtout à la vitesse à laquelle il a
laissé impressionnant a été surpris
c'est pour ça que je me suis dépêchée au
cas où vous auriez eu un signe de votre
côté là on a des signes venant d'un peu
partout maintenant il faut qu'on en
profite après tout on est ici encore que
quelques heures
tu penses que chris voudra faire la
planche oui tu sais pas ce qui vient de
se passer là un peu chamboulé que
pourrais-je pas
pour le troisième soir on a installé une
petite table dehors la table à unjat
comment l'appeler c'est là où on
essayait d'entrer en contact
j'ai le sentiment qu'avec la planche
ouija à cause de ce qu'elle représente
bon on a tous vu l'exorciste on n'était
pas tout à fait tranquille on se
demandait qu'est ce qu'on va voir plutôt
amusant mais je n'avais pas de grandes
attentes de la planche parce que je suis
pas religieux
je n'ai jamais été je ne croit pas en
ses trucs de toute façon dans mon pays
la religion est très importante dans la
famille c'est un endroit très religieux
la plupart des gens que je connais sont
catholiques de là où julien la planche
luigia pour moi c'est un outil qui peut
être très nocif
je pense que rien de bon ne peut
découler de son utilisation je reconnais
aucune situation où quelqu'un s'en est
servi et là les personnes sont reparties
chez elle en étant heureuse il ya plein
d'exemples de personnes possédé par un
esprit parce qu'il les avait suivis s'il
est vraiment nécessaire de savoir si on
invite à communiquer avec nos premières
choses une prière est importante il faut
aussi faire très sombre sur la nature de
cet homme en mai amis et moi voudrions
communiquer avec vous si vous êtes là
pouvez-vous
le faire savoir à votre manière bouger
le pointeur vous pouvez utiliser
d'autres moyens de chez nous fait un
bruit tout ce que vous voulez pour qu'on
sache que vous êtes là
montrez-nous quelque chose
ils ont fait une partie si on peut
appeler ça comme ça ne s'est rien
produit
et puis kevin m'a regardé et m'a dit
triste tu veux essayer
j'étais un peu réticente à les rejoindre
je n'avais pas envie de le faire donc
j'y suis allée à reculons c'est certain
je me suis assise et je me suis dit à
moi-même qui ne se passerait peut-être
rien jusqu'ici ça a été le cas nous
avons employé nouvelle méthode nous
avons utilisé une bague
cette bague mais très cher et j'y tiens
beaucoup c'est en fait c'est la bac de
mon père est mort il ya 25 ans c'était
son alliance
alors je suis partant pour essayer avec
ça on va tous appuyer notre un accessit
d'accord
s'il y a des esprits ce soir parmi nous
communiquer avec nous grâce à la planche
s'il vous plaît pour ce genre de session
je m'entoure raid de personnes qui
savent ce qu'elles font qui s'y
connaissent en fantôme et en esprit en
général et envoyons en qui j'ai
confiance
il vous faut ces personnes là elles ont
de l'expérience je ne m'engagerai jamais
là dedans sans cesse
c'est quoi ça j'ai eu peur pas mal pour
un début
c'était trop bizarre elle a sauté comme
ça on l'avait senti partira aussi
s'accroître comme si elle vibre et elle
était là et puis je
enfin je sais pas c'est extrêmement
bizarre dites nous si vous êtes là
elle bouge elle bouge
il s'est déplacé sur le s
touche à peine c'est fascinant après
quelques minutes c'est indéniable il y
avait des mouvements dans la baquet et
puis avec les planches via s'est jamais
vraiment si un esprit fait bouger la
bague ou si quelqu'un la pousse avec son
doigt ou le poids des doigts est trop
lourd oui ce n'était pas nécessairement
fait exprès mais on peut bouger son
doigt accidentellement
cercle la bague a ensuite bouger de
lettre en lettre
on n'avait aucune idée de ce qu'était le
mot que cet esprit était en train dé
pelé a décidé de compter les lettres et
de les noter
il avait maximum cette lettre six ou
sept je crois bien ça n'avait aucun sens
je ne pouvais même pas prononcer le mot
il commencer par la lettre s mais ç'a
donné le mot secor quelque chose comme
ça ça ne voulait absolument rien dire
mais quand on est rentré à la maison on
a fait des recherches sur le mot ils
formaient un anagramme et en remettant
les lettres à leur place apparemment en
latin le mot veut dire suivrait ce qui
après la découverte des terres plus si
drôle finale et le problème c'est que je
ne suis pas convaincu que qui que ce
soit parmi nous connaissent le latin on
emploie des mots latins comme tout le
monde mais que l'un d'eux est gardé en
mémoire le mot sequor ça me paraît quand
même impossible vraiment c'est quelque
chose que je ne m'explique toujours pas
d'ailleurs une fois qu'on s'est rendu
compte qu'on était tombé sur une zone
sensible on s'est dit que ce serait une
bonne idée que peut-être chacun d'entre
nous passent dix minutes seul passé dix
minutes tout seul était une expérience
basée sur ce que sony et ses copains
avaient vécu quelques années avant quand
on l'a interviewé il faisait jour il y
avait plein de gens autour et il a dit
qu'il ne se passerait rien à ce moment
mais que s'il était seul il se passerait
sûrement quelque chose alors on s'est
dit pourquoi on essaierait pas ça
on passe chacun dix minutes dans la zone
des tombes on installe les caméras et on
voit ce qui se passe les 10 minutes
passées parmi les tombes seul dans la
nuit
mon coeur battait à toute vitesse parce
que je n'avais aucune envie de me
balader là tout seul
toujours pas l'impact ivité particulière
rien d'important jusqu'ici c'est bientôt
l'heure des apparitions et des bruits
une heure du matin
attenton rome a pris un nouveau tournant
que ça va aller bonne chance mais qu a
besoin mais merci et bon soir bien le
bonsoir
bon ça se passe rien de trés renversant
à vrai dire un rien à déclarer pas un
bruit
sérieux painchaud est mince ou prêts
pour mes dix minutes de gloire
je devrai jouer ma capuche voilà tu vas
entendre la lune nous éclaire super
merci marc
à
et qui ici
un petit peu de remue-ménage vient de là
bas j'ai raté le renard viré
dans ma lampe
[Applaudissements]
il ya fait des bruits de panama j'ai
entendu des bas je ne sais pas ce que
c'est gilles où personne n attendait que
tu as du mouvement là-bas mac
des prête noms du tout du fait partie ma
grande en suis obligé la taille est pas
ces crises car oui elle est en chemin
elle s'avance vers l'église là
hélas
on m'a demandé de ne pas parler du tout
pendant ces dix minutes donc à oublier
des bruits
les garçons où il ya du bruit derrière
moi je suis quoi ça passe pas loin
tu as dit que tu entendait des bruits
quel genre de bruit comme avec sony
ouais
ça bouge vraiment beaucoup par ici
ça va durer encore longtemps combien de
temps je dois rester ici
il a bel et bien quelque chose qui remue
des quoi
il passait il repasse
à punaiser
enfin je vais pouvoir y aller hourra
mais dix minutes sont écoulées
ça faisait un peu ça donne elton john
qui a créé
pas de problème il vient d'arriver tu
passes le talkie walkie et je suis hyper
contente de laisser ma place parce que
franchement le bruit infernal
notre maître l'a vraiment beaucoup de
bruit ouais quelque chose marche dans
les buissons
et sur les graviers je te promets
sérieux ça car d'état torche allumée
c'est clair qu'est ce que tu crois je
veux pas mourir d'une crise cardiaque
orage a tout de suite à d'autres elle
arrive et kourou mais je crois oui un
réveil coup vous pouvez voir que je fais
debout devant l'endroit où les
différentes personnes ont vu les
apparitions
même si ta voix dans le talk qui m'a
foutu une énorme trou imec
il ya quelque chose c'est évident
vous entendez ça
bon alors j'ai dû mouvement ici je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est un
chien autres mais un chien se montrerait
à un moment donné je vais commencer à
parler à cette présence lui poser des
questions est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un ici
qui aimeraient me parler nous ne sommes
pas ici pour vous faire du mal
mais pour entrer en contact avec vous et
pourquoi pas voir si on ne peut pas vous
aider un peu
est ce que c'est vous êtes vous avec moi
il ya beaucoup de bruit là bas dans les
puits sont il fait noir mais je vois que
ça bouge
[Musique]
je crois bien que même la sécurité l'a
peut-être entendu aussi parce que je
vois leurs torches s'agiter et les
brandissent dans la même direction que
le bruit tout au bout du petit chemin là
bas
kevin lima comment ça se passe là haut
ça va plutôt bien
la caméra est en train de tourner pour
ce qui est des alentours
c'est plutôt calme en ce moment ok tu
nous prévient s'il se passe quelque
chose diminue de 7h10 clap
c'est quoi ça
il ya des bruits c'est sûr je les
entends bien derrière la tombe à côté de
l'arbre
tu peux bien toi ouais il est calé
derrière la tombe
il entend des choses derrière la tombe
quand tu dis étrange tentant quoi ça
respire ça bouge quatre genres bon ben
si c'est calme là bas ça fait un peu de
chance les micros le capteur 5 minutes
maintenant
il a fait la moitié du temps et quelque
chose ici c'est sûr je vais aller voir
mark i les hourras bill fabien il a dit
qu'il se sentait pas bien
il avait besoin de respirer il allait à
la voiture se reposer d'accord pas de
souci à lockerbie unités toujours là ça
va on en est à combien de temps là ça
fait 8 minutes de vigne c'est mike tu en
est à huit minutes dans une minute on va
venir te chercher comment ça va
on devrait gagner on va attendre 10
minutes
c'est la condition qu'on s'est donné
donc je veux pas l'interrompre
je m'inquiète un peu il répond pas et ça
fait 8 minutes ouais je sais il va
répondre et il faut espérer bon ça y'a
dix minutes way allons-y vous êtes
presque la rive le temps qu'on arrive ça
fera dix minutes voulu éclairer par la
levée
balade et voilà m
bon alors
sûrement aller kevin thème on va aller
voir cabine
venez on va le chercher il marre de ce
côté d'accord la caméra est toujours en
train de filmer oui elle tourne la
normale in fine à une lampe avec lui il
va pas être bien loin il nous a sûrement
entendu devrait rester ici au cas où
mark et moi on va faire un tour
pas par derrière d'accord j'espère
marque six mois de prêt ok
c'est bizarre
ouais
j'sais pas
peut-être partie par ce chemin je vais
là d'accord mais ils nous l'auraient dit
qu'ils seraient allumés et là
d'antan juste la caféine j'ai entendu
quelque chose ça viendra c'est ouaga à
temps mais ces radios sa cabine
donc ça ya de la lumière là bas c'est
son talkie walkie
où est passé kevin tu veux quelque chose
bouger là tout va bien bébé ouais voilà
trop de moi
par douce prend pas redouter
quand j'étais là-bas
j'ai entendu des pas aussi quelqu'un
marché et ça venait de derrière les
tournages
encore plus surprenant j'ai vu une ombre
isin de couleur sombre et la bouche et
de gauche à droite juste là devant les
tailles et amman
j'entends plus ni micky ni marque
ils sont partis à tous attention
attention fais gaffe aux branches ils
sont passés par ce côté pour le chercher
mais face à voir
l'apa talkie walkie avec nous alors
commencer
[ __ ] merde quoi c'est pas vrai il faut
qu'on parte ya un truc
thierry bbd ouais carrément lien [ __ ]
de truc là-bas
en face la dans les buissons ou qu'est
ce qu'il ya ils ont vu quelque chose
dans les buissons ya un truc là-bas et
ça marche les 2 du tomber je ne sais
rien il y avait quelque chose de bizarre
je sais pas ce que c'était on enrichit
une tête peur et s'est enfui il publie
j'ai maintenant je crois qu'elle s'est
tordu la cheville non j'ai pas si elle
est on n'arrête pas trembler depuis tout
à l'heure il faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose allait voir là-bas valérie sourcil
saillie encore sur tes jambes jerry des
mois durée vous avez remarqué
non j'ai éclairé l'endroit avec mme
allan n'avait rien à bb je ne peux pas
marcher vous la mettre au chaud femmes
non là dans l'église
allez tiens bon alors hop cemac
tu m'entends je vous promets j'ai eu la
trouille de ma vie
les pierres tombales c'est allé voir les
mecs
ouais je suis allé j'ai rien vu moi
aussi j'ai balader mal an partout mais
j'ai rien vu si c'était l'info qui
essayait de nous faire une mauvaise
blague je l'aurais su messins s'étaient
pas normal sur ma vie c'était pas dans
vannes
pas mieux de partir ouais ça suffit
je salue
[Musique]
par ici
ce serait cool si l'un de vous pouvez
rester avec crise pendant que moi ok on
va continuer de chercher ici on vient
dans une minute pas de souci
c'est là
c'est par ici
j'ai passé une très bonne idée il y
avait une tête ici c'est pas une blague
tu regarde la vidéo tu la verras
ça continue par là
ce mois
je
quel côté
je sais rien
d'akalé par là
dans l'attenté temps là ok
je les vois tu
qu'est ce qu'ils font
je sais pas
du coup
on fait quoi ne s'en va [ __ ] merde
alors
j'hallucine [ __ ] tu crois qu'ils nous
suivent je suis pas riche mais plus tard
haché
tendu ça c'était quoi
merdy sont là c'est pas vrai
bien allé chez toi
et
merde
vous êtes là
ban
la police était présente sur toute la
zone de l'église quand craig et moi
sommes revenus on leur a dit ce qui
s'était passé ce qu'on avait vu son
parti inspecter l'endroit où on était
quand ils sont remontés ils ont dit
qu'il y avait personne en bas ils n'ont
absolument rien vu du tout
une fois entré chez nous cette nuit là
que c'est moi n'était vraiment pas bien
on savait que ce n'était pas fini tu te
sens comment
trop fatiguée qu'elle se remettait à
peine de ce qui lui était arrivé elle se
sentait de mieux en mieux il faut dire
qu'elle avait reçu un assez gros coup
émotionnellement il était à peu près 4
heures du matin quand on est rentré et
j'étais vraiment pas enfin j'étais
fatigué aussi très affaibli on voulait
juste aller dormir et ne plus penser à
rien du tout au moins jusqu'au lendemain
on va essayer de faire tout cela parce
que les petites sont en train de dormir
il est en ligne au chaud sur wii bonnes
idées on les enlève et on en direct
merde chez vous rien du tout les filtres
au port je vais mettre la vision nuit
sur la caméra sera pas résolu mais je
trouve pas le bouton
ainsi le voilà bah merde qui se dit
qu'evelyne est là debout devant nouveau
se tenait notre fille de 6 ans kate les
elle avait la tête penchée en avant ses
cheveux couvrait entièrement son visage
et franchement c'est notre fille on lève
de tout notre coeur mais sûrement
ça nous a fait un choc de la voir comme
ça à cette heure-là de la nuit dans le
noir complet
on ne s'y attendait pas fois que dali si
celui-ci la lumière s'il te plaît ils
ont plié et devant elle
à ses pieds étaient couchés l'intro
grande croix du christ qui est
habituellement accrochée en haut des
escaliers
comment elle est arrivée là j'en ai
aucune idée et pourquoi est ce que ma
fille de 6 ans se tenait debout sans
bouger au milieu du salon à 4 heures du
matin
je ne pourrais pas l'expliquer c'est
tout elle sans rendez compte de rien on
ne pouvait pas l'arrivée crise était en
panique
c'est normal je pense après ce qu'elle
venait de vivre
donc j'ai tout fait pour qu'elle se
calme un peu je lui ai dit que tout
irait bien j'ai pris quelques lignes
dans mes bras et les portés jusque dans
sa chambre est gelée recoucher fait beau
rêve mais pompey
pas de problème elle a continué de
dormir on avait vécu quelques
expériences dans passé avec kathleen
quand elle était très jeune en matière
de communication avec l'au delà
mais on croyait que c'était fini parce
qu'elle entrait dans la joue si j'ai
bien compris et d'après ce que je sais
où si les enfants des expériences
paranormales
ils peuvent perdre un peu les pédales
mais elle est venue nous voir
le lendemain matin le jour d'après en
fait elle nous a dit que quelqu'un de
nouveau lui parlait une personne qu'elle
n'avait jamais vu et que cette personne
n'était pas très gentil et qu'il voulait
faire du mal et qu'il faisait semblant
d'être son ami
ce n'est pas son genre inventé des
histoires pareilles elle parle souvent
de cet ami depuis ce matin là elle en a
parlé à plusieurs reprises et par
conséquent
brisset pétrifiés à l'idée de passer du
temps à la maison tout seul je ressens
de l'inquiétude
et j'ai aussi beaucoup de mal à me
sentir à l'aise chez moi dire et c'est
peut-être tout dans la tête mais j'ai
déjà vécu ça quand j'étais en espagne
je me disais peut-être que c'est rien
mais peut-être qu'il ya vraiment quelque
chose toutes les choses inexplicables
qui se sont déroulés à clap ils sont à
mon avis lié avec le fait qu'une entité
ou du moins une présence nous a suivis
jusque chez nous j'en suis sûr dans la
mesure du possible nous voudrions éviter
de faire peur aux enfants
mais si ça continue il faudra envisager
une solution peut-être même déménagé je
ne peux pas vous dire qui se cache là où
je ne peux même pas vous dire s'il ya
quelqu'un
c'est à chacun d'y aller de se faire sa
propre opinion je pense